you are a tall young man yeah I'm a long
drink of water baby you already know
what it is
I I did the I did the pre-show and I had
a
white and purple earlier now I'm going
black and purple
and song the name was inspired by Betty
White correct because you just have it
it was I mean I I
on every album I put at least one song
named after a MILF and uh what is the
obsession with
more experience they are an under
service Community I'd like to say and
they deserve more attention so I thought
that I'd be the one and I I've noticed
that people really really have started
giving males more attention since my
music dropped and honey I think well you
seem to be given some of them more
attention as well
my day's not here right now around the
corner but yes wait absolutely I do
believe was that Sherry Sarah Nicole is
she your date tonight my date tonight
yes no way yes way really yeah
we may we may we yeah
I would say I was just saying how
MILFs you know deserve more attention
and that I she was complimenting my date
so I thought it was perfect timing
when did you ask this lovely lady to be
here plus the moment that I I knew I was
coming to the VMAs I did yes really
what is it about young gravy
he's very wholesome I would say
believe it or not I am a wholesome
person I am a wholesome well
congratulations
your VMA performance tonight thank you
so much I appreciate it congratulations
on your collaboration
thank you very much watch out for Martha
you might have to just
ice
is the queen Legend genius a lot of love
for Martha shout out to Martha Stewart
foreign